欢迎各位车灵今天这期摆车圈说我是三刀。
今天这期节目咱们来聊一聊前段时间车圈里面非常热门的一个事件。
就是比亚迪智驾兜底这件事儿。
而且发布会的名字起的也很好啊，叫感维。
现在发布会就跟打仗一样，什么都是名字起的特别热血啊。
那么当时有一个这个热门歌曲啊，这也是非常的洗脑，就是那个腾歌尔唱的。
所以他们讲说比亚迪终于招到大学生了。
所以现在这个宣传模式非常的年轻化啊。
大家有看到这个评论我就笑了半天啊，非常非常有意思。
就说明比亚迪以前的这种宣传给人感觉就飞到老派，那工程师文化嘛，对吧。
那么这件事情呢是5月28号，当时比亚迪开了这么一个发布会。
那么这个发布会呢，主要就说了三件事情。
第一件事情就是四纳米芯片玄机A3正式量产。
那么第二件事情呢，就是CNOA城市领航一年安全兜底政策落地。
第三件事情，天生之眼B，激光力打板，选装成本1.2万。
那么高阶支架下放到7万元的入门车型。
其实这三件事情都是相关连的啊。
芯片呢解决的就是比亚迪有没有能力把支架的核心能够掌握在自己手里面。
那么城市领航呢，它这个兜底其实要解决就是消费者你不敢用，对吧。
那我兜底你还敢不敢用啊。
他当时不是也给了一个数据嘛，说当年智能博车啊，不兜底是这么个比例。
那么兜底完之后翻了四倍啊，一会后面我们再展开来讲。
那么还有一个就是高阶支架下放到7万块钱这个级别的车型。
那么7万元级说实话啊，就已经你不能再低了吧，你再低的话就是3万5万了，对吧。
就五零红光迷你EV，它现在价格也不止3万多了，当年刚开始的时候卖的便宜啊。
现在也是慢慢的想把这个总价往上稍微提一提啊，
但是不管怎么说呢，也是5万元级的车啊，
7万元级在往下真的就是入门级的入门级的入门了，就A00了，A00级车了。
所以它解决的就是这一套东西能不能大规模的普及啊，要放量。
当然了，这前面我们讲比阿迪发布会宣布了三件事情，那节目开头我要宣布第四件事情啊，
就是最近大强子给我们的摆设选说的粉丝定制了京东红包，点击评论区置顶的链接啊，就可以领取。
有的时候呢，我可能这个链接发的稍微晚一点啊，如果发的稍微晚一点呢，
你就去我上一期节目看，反正最近这几期的置顶都是这个链接。
你点击这个链接，就可以领取红包，然后呢放到你自己的这个京东账号里面，随时都可以用。
那么它可以跟你的折扣卷叠加在一起用，每天最多可以领三次，先领红包在下单，
记得一定要看清楚这个红包的有效期啊。
那么这个第四件事情我也说完了，那么接着就聊聊今天的重点，
也就是比阿迪发布会上的这个第二点，那么CNOA城市领行一年安全兜底政策，
啊网上就叫做支架兜底嘛，这个是到怎么回事呢。
虽然说这个一听就懂啊，就是你开支架的这个功能在路上开车，
如果出了事故，比阿迪来兜底，但这里面呢有很多的细节，还是要展开来去把它搞清楚，
要不然的话你现在去买比阿迪，对吧，他真的给你支架兜底了，你也搞不懂这里面具体什么规则，
啊你真的如果说要是开了个支架出了个事故，那到底按照什么流程赔呢，
那比阿迪他是真的赔我吗，啊他以什么样的标准来确认是支架的问题，还是我的问题呢，
对吧，那万一中间你要是没搞清楚再再扯扯皮什么的，那最终这个双方不换二三这个对吧，
那品牌说我也很冤枉，你说我也很冤枉，对吧，你还骂品牌不舍心用，
那么其实首先啊我们解释清楚，CNOA其实就是城市领航的英文缩写啊，
那么城市领航一年兜底，我们后面就全部叫支架兜底好吧，就简单点讲，
它其实指的就是你合规开启CNOA城市领航，那么因为支架系统的故障造成了本方有责，
本方有责事故，就是你的修车费，壮坏别人的车，还有物品，商者的医疗费，
全部都是有比亚迪出钱全额赔付，没有赔付的上限，记住了是没有赔付上限啊，
那么不用车主去走它的保险，也不会涨第二年的保费，那么这个保障有效期是固定12个月，
那么这里面其实有一个非常重要的细节是什么，我估计有人应该注意到了，
因支架系统故障造成本方有责事故，第二个是什么，就是时间，一开始可能有些人还以为是终身，对吧，
因为如果没有看发布会的话，只听说一个什么比亚迪滴滴兜兜兜兜兜兜，就比亚迪兜底了，
它不是的，都一年，都一年，那这个一年怎么算呢，
这个一年是新车，2026年5月28号不是宣布了吗，从这一天开始，
然后到2027年5月28号，就是这一年当中上了牌的新车，有天神之眼A，有天神之眼B配置的，
从提车当天算起，那么往后它就保你一整年，那有人说老车子呢，老车子是这样的，
已经在开的，也是具备天神之眼A，天神之眼B的车型，车辆OTA升级到天神之眼5.0版本，
从升级当天开始，算，算一年，它给你兜底，那么天神之眼C，
因为它不在这个城市NOA，所以它也没有激光力达嘛，它就不在这个兜底范围之内，
那么有些人认为是终身，其实终身不是指的这个城市的自驾领航兜底，
终身指的是他们家还有一个叫做博车辅助，
它那个自动博车是从去年7月份开始宣布是这个终身有效的，
而且它那个终身有效即使你转手，成为二手车，那博车出事故的话，
厂家也是赔的，所以它那个是智能博车或者叫自动博车，
跟天神之眼A，天神之眼B的这样一个智能驾驶，就是城区支驾辅助的兜底，
不是一个概念，所以这个一定要分开，要不然的话有的人认为说，
兜底不都是终身的嘛，不是的，博车是终身的，这个不是终身，
这个只管一年，那么比亚迪的城市领航一年兜底，
它跟市面上已有的那些支驾显有什么样的区别呢，
其实主要区别有三点，那么首先一点，这个是属于厂家给的免费权益，
它也不卖，它就是送，然后它也不是商业保险，你也不要去花钱，
就是你之前老车主的你升级OTA就给，那么你现在新车主，
那你买了就给，就是这样的，那么第二个就是保险赔付，
它是根据保额制定它的赔付上限，就是说你花了多少钱，
然后我保险赔付的上限额度是多少，我是给你之前定好的，合同是约定死的，
但是这个赔付它是没有上限的，它是上不封定的，
我们能看到有一些这种比较严重的事故，就一辆车把五车追尾，
或者是一辆车就扎到人堆里面了，我们讲就极端一点，
那你想想看，生命无价，生命是无价的，你即使是保险公司，
它这个赔付它也要是根据你的保额来的，对不对，
所以这个还是说句实在话，风险是比较大的，
因为到目前为止我真没听说过，不管是财险还是受险，
有没有做保险的兄弟们，您能说说看，
市面上有不设上限赔付的保险吗？
反正我据我了解我的认知范围内是没有的，
任何的保险公司敢说我这个保险是上不封顶，那这个风险极大呀，
那是极大，你别说上不封顶一辆普通的车的保险了，
你就是老斯拉艾斯，南波经理法拉利，
很多的这些车型买保险一家保险公司也不敢保，
很多公司都是一个城保方然后几个联保，
保险公司再买保险，几家就是分摊保险，
因为它收的费用也高，对吧，
所以有些超跑超豪车主他就不买商业鞋，
他就买一个交响鞋就在路上开了，
所以一定要遇到这种车子要离得远一点，
那这是第二个，第三个是什么呢，
就是因为质价的问题发生了事故之后，
你就可以不走保险了，
因为我后面要说的一个叫双保险制度，
就是你正常报保险还是正常报，
但是保险明年的保费涨不涨，
是根据他赔没赔，不是根据你报没报，
你报了保险他没赔，对吧，
你说我撤销了，我想了一下我还是自己掏钱修，
那就没出现啊，你虽然报了保险，
但就是没出现啊，你以后查不到这种出现记录的，
你不要认为说我报了个保险，
我将来卖二手车是不是这个记录就能查得到，
你报保险的记录是查不到的，
但是保险赔付了以后这个记录是能查得到的，
所以这个你要搞清楚啊，
所以它是不赔付就不走保险出现记录，
所以你来连到这个保费是不涨的，
那么什么叫双保险制度呢，
我们就接着把它展开来讲一讲吧，
这个双保险制度啊，
这个双保险制度简单来讲就是你同一起事故，
车主既可以报自己的商业车险，
又可以去报质价险，
或者就是像比亚迪这种叫品牌兜底服务，
那么因为保险行业它有个基本的原则，
什么原则呢，就是同一个损失不能重复获利，
或者叫重复获益，
那么因此如果某一个人的车它撞了之后，
车损最后定下来是5万块钱，
那么商业险已经赔了一次了，
那么另外一个保险，
或者说另外一个服务，
它就不能再把同样的5万块钱重复赔给你，
这个是保险行业的一个基本的原则，
那么比亚迪其实就是要规避这个问题，
其实它规不规避，
它也不属于保险，
反正它就只要规避一下，
那具体怎么操作呢，
就比如说张三开着一台大载天成之眼A，
或者天成之眼B的比亚迪，
那么在合规开启城市NOA领航辅助的时候，
发生了一起交通事故，
你看我这个前面的定语，
就讲得要非常清楚，
合规开启城市NOA领航辅助的时候，
那发生事故之后呢，
那张三应该是，
该报警就报警，
打一二，该拍照就拍照，
对吧,
那么该联系保安公司，
就打自己保安公司电话，
那么这个事故发生的时候，
为什么要这么操作，
因为你要把相关的这些，
就是现场的照片，
你要把它锁定，
因为最后是要定责任的嘛，对吧，
那么你也不可能第一时间知道，
这个是不是自驾系统的责任，
因为你完全不知道，
大多数的消费者都是小白用户，
哪怕就是比较专业的一些消费者，
他也懂什么叫自驾，
但是他也不能完全确认，
这一次的事故是不是自驾，
他的责任，
所以按照常规的流程，
你先把这个照片该拍就拍，
电话该打就打，
报交警报保险，
那么剩下来流程就是交警定责，
保险就查看现场，
或者说保险就问一下什么情况，
对吧，小金额他就不看了嘛，
然后接着就是修车礼陪，
然后根据你的出现的次数，
出现的金额，
明年的保费就跟着会涨一些，
那么现在等于是多了一步，
就叫做双保险制度，
什么叫多了一步呢？
就是张三还要再打开比亚迪的这个app，
手机app,
或者说你也可以直接联系比亚迪的官方售后，
一般用手机app联系售后也很方便，
那么这一次事故，
你还得要上报给比亚迪，
申请城市领航安全都底，
然后比亚迪这边就会进入到后台去核查，
这里面有个很关键的点，
这怎么核查呢？
总不能说安排一个人过来，
就现场给你把车拆开来看一看，
这个车支架也没有问题，
不是这样子的，
就是对车主来讲，
支架系统其实就是一个盲盒，
或者说是个黑盒，
你根本就不知道里面的这一套系统是怎么运作的，
你只知道你反正车是怎么开的，
支架是怎么启动的，
最后你是怎么撞的，
你可能也大概就知道一点，
但是你就不知道这个事故发生前几秒，
这个系统到底他是怎么判断的，
他看到了什么，
他下达了什么样的一个指令，
他最后做出了什么样的动作，
这个你是不是很清楚，
那么比亚迪后台的技术人员，
对于他们来讲，
其实这个我们看到的什么黑盒盲盒，
对他来讲是个透明的盒子，
因为他能看到这个底层的数据，
他可以去调取这个事故发生前后的一些数据，
然后去分析，
就当时城市领航辅助，
有没有正常开启，
车辆有没有处在一个功能适用的范围之内，
驾驶员有没有长时间的脱手，
传感器有没有异常，
摄像头当时看到了什么，
系统有没有识别到前方的车辆和行人，
包括自动转向加减速，
这些指令是怎么发出去的，
然后事故发生前，
有没有出现人车博弈的情况，
所以说白了，
就是说事故发生前后的，
那么几秒后的几十秒钟，
他完全可以一针一针的把它拆解开来，
一针一针就是画面一针一针，
把它拆解开来，
那么如果说后台数据显示说，
张三当时，
他确确实实是合规使用城市领航辅助系统，
那么同时这个系统，
也确实出现了识别错误，
判断错误，
或者说执行策略有问题，
那么这个事故发生，
毫无疑问，
他就可以认定为，
符合兜底条件，
那么这个兜底条件，
一旦要是符合的话，
那么比亚迪就会启动赔付，
因为我们刚刚前面讲了，
你如果有责，
那么张三你自己的车损，
对吧，比亚迪承担的，
那么如果你撞了别人的车，
第三方的车辆，
或者说第三方的财产损失，
那么比亚迪也是承担的，
甚至于我看到有个案例，
因为已经有人在赔付了，
他甚至车上的车医破损，
比亚迪一也是承担的，
那么毫无疑问，
将来如果遇到一些大的问题点，
比方说涉及人伤事故，
那么按道理讲，
按照他这个程度来讲的话，
那么应该一也是有比亚迪承担的，
那么这些钱都不是从张三的。
商业保险里面走，
那么也就是说，
张三虽然前面报了保险，
但是最后实际上，
这个赔付都是由比亚迪来兜底的，
那保卫公司是不是很开心，
你看,
那我以后是不是应该给比亚迪。
降降保费，
比亚迪这边都兜底了，
那将来出事故，
说不定有一定的概率，
都是由比亚迪来赔付，
真有可能，
他真有可能，
以后比亚迪的保费会降，
而且你想个问题，
你以后，
但反出了事故，
有没有可能，
管他是不是质价的问题，
全部给他包上去吗？
我这个工作量可不低啊，
真不低啊，
甚至于有没有可能，
这个人连质价都没开过，
他都没启动过，
但是出了事故之后，
管他三七二十一呢，
我就用比亚迪的App，
我就报一个事故，
我就说你质价有问题，
对不对，
那怎么样去确定，
所以这个确定的范围，
确定的这个标准和规则，
一定要公正公开，
要不然我跟你讲，
这个事情到后面，
很扯皮，
非常扯皮，
所以这个人心啊，
迫策,
人心格度皮，
你永远不知道，
因为这个还，
它不叫骗保险，
对不对，
我也不知道这个，
如果要是骗比亚迪的厂家，
到底是按照什么样的一个，
规则来去判定，
你要是骗保险，
那是要做老大，
对不对，
你开玩笑啊，
你骗险，
你这是要做老大，
但是你这个，
你这个骗比亚迪，
对吧,
你说出事故要骗他钱，
我就搞不清楚，
这到底怎么办了，
不知道我们的这个，
评论区里面，
有专业的律师朋友，
能够解答一下这个问题啊，
我很想知道，
那么同样啊，
这个车子，
因为都是比亚迪赔了嘛，
没走保险，
所以你的来年的保费，
是不受影响的，
那么这就是比亚迪，
这套方案，
跟普通的，
这个保险的，
一个最大的区别，
包括市面上这个质价，
最大的区别，
当然了，
这个事情呢，
我们反过来也要说清楚，
如果比亚迪后台，
核查出来说，
这个事故不是他的，
质价系统的责任，
而是驾驶员没有及时接管，
或者说你当时，
根本就没有合规开启，
城市领航，
或者车辆，
它不再是功能适用的范围之内，
那就不属于兜底范围，
那么如果比亚迪，
判定不属于兜底范围，
这个时候呢，
怎么办，
那怎么办呢，
那你这个事故，
就要回到正常的，
车显的这个理沛流程，
所以这就是，
为什么我讲说，
一旦要是出了，
这个相关的事故，
你本管是不是支假的问题，
你现场照片，
保养公司你该报就报，
然后这个交警那边，
你是该报，
报案，背案就背案，
所以这个到最后，
你要是被判定，
不是支假的问题，
你打回来，
走这个流程的话，
那么该谁负责，
还是谁负责，
该保险你赔，
还是保险你赔，
那么有人肯定要问，
说这个比亚迪，
后台的数据，
来判断，
是不是支假的责任，
那么消费者，
如果质疑，
这个数据有问题呢，
那么再极端一点，
如果消费者觉得，
这个数据是比亚迪，
篡改过的呢，
对不对，
你又是运动员，
又是裁判员，
车企你自己掌握数据，
你自己解释数据，
最后你说自己没有责任，
那消费者，
是不是一点办法都没有呢，
其实这个担忧呢，
我觉得不有道理啊，
讲的确有道理，
那么我们也可以简单分析一下，
就如果说一边，
比亚迪说，
我们支假都，
一边呢，
比亚迪说，
我也要去篡改数据，
当然他不会说，
就是他私底下，
我要去推卸责任，
那么对比亚迪，
对于一家公司来讲，
是利大于币呢，
还是币大于利呢，
因为现在互联网都是透明的，
一旦要是被实锤，
那我的天哪，
可想而知这个负面，
那这个负面，
可不是一天两天，
能够把这个新人给挽回的啊，
首先啊，
我们先讲这个车企，
他想要随便的去，
篡改这个质价的相关数据，
或者说车企，
车辆的这个后台的数据，
有没有那么简单，
其实没有那么简单啊，
现在的车辆，
他不是说一条数据列，
事故发生前后，
车上会有行车记录仪的画面，
摄像头感知的数据，
毫米玻璃达的数据，
车速，自动转向，
油门方向盘接管，
还有系统提示，
驾驶员的状态监测等等，
它是一套，
叫日致，
就一整套日致，
很多关键的数据，
还会写入ED2，
我们之前也解释过这个ED2，
那美就是说，
汽车的事件，
它的整个数据，
这样的一套记录系统，
你不是说想改就能改的，
而且你说句实在话，
你千一发而动全身，
你改一个还不行，
你要改，
你要把它全部给包装的，
特别像，
所以这个东西不是讲说，
就是什么，
1加1等于2，
还是等于3，
我把那个最后的结尾的，
等号后面的数字，
给它擦掉重写就行了，
它不是这么简单的一个事儿啊，
而且你都已经是要兜底了，
你都已经把数据公开了，
这个数据一旦要是展示在网上，
有个大神过来，
稍微给你实锤一下，
那小事儿就真的是变成大事儿了，
比亚迪，
你说再怎么赔钱，
这点钱你就是，
别说赔个什么几十万，几百万了，
你就赔个几千万，
对于比亚迪这种公司来讲，
那不也就是撒撒随嘛，
对不对，
但是你要是篡改数据，
放到网上被人实锤，
那就不是几千万能搞定的事情了，
这是第一点，
那么第二个呢，
就是事故现场，
也不是只有车企知道啊，
交警也有现场的勘查，
保险公司也有查看记录，
第三方的车辆，
也有可能他有行车记录仪，
那么路口也有监控，
甚至包括旁边的这些什么店铺啊，
路过的这些车辆啊，
他都是可以拍到画面的，
对不对，
那么也就是说，
比亚迪后台的数据很重要，
但是他不是唯一的证据，
那么这第二，
第三呢，
你说真的要出了一些重大的事故，
尤其是涉及到人身伤亡的事故，
而且尤其是这个事情，
万一还上了这个热搜，
大家都在关注，
车企他敢随便的篡改数据吗，
像这种严重的事故啊，
他要敢篡改的话，
那就涉及到伪造证据，
妨碍司法，
甚至是就是更严重的法律责任了，
对吧,
所以说他为了逃一笔这个所谓的赔付，
然后去冒这种法律和品牌信用的风险，
那么对这个车企来讲，
这笔账怎么算都不划算啊，
那么你老老实实去赔钱，
那别人还给你叫个好，
你品牌还能增加你的这个，
这个叫品牌信任度，对吧，
老百姓觉得说，
你看，就比亚迪敢说敢当，
敢做敢当，
说什么承诺，
他就可以去兑现，
那这个去信用加分啊，
信用加分多卖几辆车，
那钱不就回来了嘛，对不对，
所以左边是赔，
右边是赚，
这笔账到底是怎么衡量，
比亚迪其实是在承诺之前，
早已经算得很清楚了，
那么花耳说回来，
消费者为什么会有这个担心，
因为数据啊，
他确确实实，
就是掌握在车企手里面的，
那你坐在驾驶座上面，
你每天开车，
那你能感受到什么呢，
你其实感受不到什么，
你感受不到这个系统的，
就是那一瞬间，
它到底是做了，
怎么样那个判断，
下达了怎么样个指令，
所以你就是跟车企之间信息不对的，
对吧,
你不能说我自己从车企，
这个车辆上面，
我调出一个后台数据，
我本官懂不懂，
我马上我这边出了事故，
我马上我自己把这个数据，
锁定,
我就发到网上，
你没有这个能力啊，
只有厂家有这个能力啊，
所以比亚迪这次到底，
真正考验的是什么，
我觉得不是说，
老王在台上讲，
我们承诺，我们都赔，
这后面就什么事都解决了，
不是这样子这么简单的，
后面的责任，
认定机制够不够透明，
够不够公开，
这个非常关键，
其实最理想的状态是什么，
我觉得最理想的状态是这样的，
也不能全让车企说了算，
它应该有一套，
这个第三方介入的机制，
大家都认可的第三方，
然后呢，
小事故，
那么车企相当于是快速理赔，
车企就快速的判断，
说这是我们这个支架的问题，
小碰小擦，
那我就给你赔了，
那这样效率是非常高的，
但如果一旦是大的事故，
有争议的事故，
消费者不认可的这个事故，
那么我觉得是应该允许，
有个第三方的监听机构，
有保险公司，
或者是监管部门，
或者是司法机构，
他们来去调取相关的原始数据，
然后去做独立的判断，
这个责任到底是不是支架的问题，
而且这个一旦要是打通了，
其他的车企都可以学啊，
这绝对是个好事啊，
现在其实只要聊到智能驾驶辅助，
或者说支架这个事情啊，
网上都会吵，
那网友之间为什么会吵架呢，
很简单，
一边是车企在发布会上拼命的讲，
我们家的系统有多先进啊，
我们家的系统有多智能啊，
能自动变道，
能够进出杂道，
能够像老司机一样去开车，
那么另外一边呢，
新闻媒体也是隔三差五的，
出相关的报道，
哪边哪边的这个车辆，
智能驾驶又出了问题了，
高速出事故了，
城区撞车了，
都说这个支架啊，
这个不行，那个不行的，
那左边是说支架也多先进，
右边是看到很多的新闻，
支架有多么的拉跨，
对吧，经常出问题，
那么之前上热搜的那条新闻，
大家应该也都看到，
什么三名女大学生在高速公路上，
开车去到安徽的那个桐林那附近，
结果呢撞了，
对吧，说是开了支架，
几个人在车上休息，
那么最后给出的结论是什么呢，
这是官方结论啊，
官方结论就是L2级辅助驾驶系统，
不等于自动驾驶，
驾驶员长时间依赖支架，
输于观察路况，
收到多次接管提醒，
为及时处置，
人工接管后操作失误，
撞了忽兰，
车企不承担，
交通事故主起责任，
那么这个官方的声明一放到网上，
那结果整个互联网就炸了，
为什么呢，
因为之前车企啊，
发过一个声明，
说他已经做到了提醒，
而且是最后提醒，
一秒内，
是一秒左右吧，
反正这个人工是接管了，
但是人工接管之后，
车辆还是撞墙了嘛，
还是撞了，
所以网上就在讲说，
这种速度下，
让他一秒钟立刻接管，
正常人谁反应的过来，
但是又有网友会说了，
说这本来就是辅助驾驶啊，
手就应该放在方向盘上面，
眼睛就应该看着路，
你不能把它当自动驾驶来开啊，
然后另外一波网友又开始反问了，
说那车企的发布会，
他不是这么宣传的啊，
卖车的时候，
宣传的像自己是自动驾驶一样的，
出事故的时候，
就变成了辅助驾驶了，
所以这个话题，
现在最尴尬的地方就在这儿，
就是车企在宣发的过程中，
再去宣传自己新车的时候，
他想把自己的车子包装的，
讲得更先进一些，
更智能一些，
那么消费者，
他肯定是脑补出来的画面，
就是自动驾驶的这个画面嘛，
可是一到出了这个问题的时候，
到了要谈法律责任的时候，
他又给你去谈回来说，
我们必须要回到辅助驾驶这样的一个框架里面来谈，
那么也就真因为是这样，
现在很多的平台对于我们这种自媒体，
在去试驾的过程当中，
发这些视频的时候，
表述的要求是非常非常之严格，
对厂家不严格，
但对自媒体那么严格，
他说你不能讲自驾，
你不允许讲自驾，
你必须说驾驶辅助，
甚至现在有的连智能都不能讲，
就必须说驾驶辅助，
网上都在说，
车企的发布会，
是属于不受广告法限制的发布会，
什么罪，
什么地球地表最强，
什么五千万以内，
一千万以内最好，
反正各种罪字，
都懂什么全球首发，
全球首歌什么的，
都是全球都是首，
都是第一，都是罪，
但是像我们，
在任何的这些社交平台上面，
都不让讲，
我们如果一旦要是讲什么罪，
什么这些极限词，
立刻这个，
不讲账号被封，
就是这个内容就被下架了，
是不让发出来的，
就起了怪了，
那车企的这些发布会是可以的，
然后车企，
想跟你去谈合作宣传的时候，
发给你的这些，
我们讲叫brief，
就是这些，
宣传的核心点，
宣传的资料，
那里面那些词，
你根本就不能用啊，
你想直接拿过来，
直接照超区用的话，
那这个视频，
根本就上线不了，
所以到今天为止，
你本管，
各家的智能驾驶辅助系统，
它的名字取得多么的高级，
你本管它的宣传片，
拍的有多么的科幻，
就是L2级的辅助驾驶，
它就是倒不了L23，
所以现在有人说是L2.5，
有人说叫高阶制驾，
有人说什么，
甚至L2.99999,。
它本质上就是L2，
法律逻辑上，
L2就是人来主导，
系统辅助，
驾驶员是有全程监控的义务的，
就是你手势不能离开的，
眼睛必须盯到前方，
你真正到了L3以上，
那就是另外一条，
这个相关的法律制度了，
因为现在目前还没有落地嘛，
那么系统它是在特定条件下可以接管，
驾驶任务的，
特定条件下，
那么这个时候你车企就要承担更多的系统的责任了，
因为它是允许你驾驶员手就离开放昂盘了嘛，
油门刹车你都不用去踩了嘛，
那到了L3它是相关的，
L3级别的这样的一套规定，
所以过去这个行业，
就有一个非常微妙的状态，
卖车的时候，
驾驶辅助是个卖点，
是科技感的体现，
是溢价的理由，
但是出事故的时候，
L2就是LR,
辅助就是辅助，
驾驶员仍然是第一责任人，
所以功能听起来很咸言，
责任算起来很传统，
宣传的时候像未来科技，
任责任的时候，
就像用户协议，
那这比亚迪特殊的点在哪儿了，
比亚迪说我现在兜笛了，
我兜笛，
那这个兜笛，
它其实没有说自己的系统是L3，
他说了嘛，
他从来都没说过，
他也没有说车主你可以撒手不管，
他还是个辅助，
你还是要把手扶到方向盘上面，
浮到方向盘上面 你还是要看路。
对吧 他是说 在合规使用城市领航的基础上。
驾驶员该监管还得监管 该接管还得接管 但是呢 他现在就说了 在合规使用的前提下 如果说是质价的问题。
这个账算到我头上。
这一步 其实我跟你讲 很多的车企想责。
之前就能看得出来 大家还记得我之前在聊那个帛制期的时候。
对吧 广汽的帛制 他之前不也是这么讲吗 也是说我们兜底吗？
对不对 但是他说什么什么自然兜底之类的 他其实厂家都想兜底。
质价兜底这个层面 其实主要就是责任怎么去认定。
对吧 兜底他不是发海报 兜底是真二八经要掏钱的。
技术只要有那么一丢丢的短板 流程只要有那么一丢丢的漏洞。
责任认定只要有那么一丢丢的不清楚 赔福成本可能就是个无底洞啊？
所以一般小企业他也不敢这么玩。
对吧 所以你会发现 其实比亚迪的这个支价兜底之后啊 到目前为止还没有车企去跟进。
说我也都比亚迪兜底 我也兜底 我也城市领航 我也兜底。
到今天为止还没人跟进 那为什么其他的车企他不跟进支价兜底呢？
其实这个事情出来之后啊 很多人第一反应就是肯定有品牌会跟。
我当时也觉得过个一两天啊 这个什么华为啊 什么小棚啊 对吧 这两家是支价最有名的嘛？
那多多少少也得跟一下 对不对 人家都说哈了 我也得要说一下。
但是呢 目前都没有大规模的跟进 我们一个一个的讲啊 我们先讲特斯拉 大家都知道特斯拉。
特斯拉为什么没跟进呢 那当然大家也知道特斯拉一般也不会你降价我降价 对吧 他是按照自己的玩法来。
特斯拉有个巨大的问题点在哪 也不叫问题点吧 他跟我们国内车企不太一样的点在哪。
特斯拉是一个全球统一的责任体系。
他不可能根据中国市场去制定一个啊 专门针对中国消费者的这么一个政策。
他如果一旦要说我支价兜底 那你开玩笑 他就是全球兜底了。
他是全球兜底了 对吧 他现在是坚持l2付出价式的这个责任框架 他是用规模用数据。
还有他这个 因为他是纯视觉嘛 持续迭代去降低他的事故概率 他是降低事故概率啊 他也不敢说我去兜底啊？
对不对 他是全球责任体系 他不敢兜 那么华为系呢 华为系就比方说啊 鸿蒙智形啊 这些。
华为系呢 他跟很多的新势力 他更多是用保险 就是用质价写 用权益服务啊 或者是联合第三方。
来去保障这个用户的一个所谓的质价的这个顾虑 那么这个模式呢 相对来讲更轻一些啊 对车企的压力也小一点。
而且本身这个华为也不造车嘛 对吧 所以他也跟符合现在目前行业里面常见的一种。
就是风险的一个分担的分担的一个方式。
那么鸿蒙智形目前是什么效果呢 就是他目前执行的是。
首任车主高速NOA 首年免费兜底 也是第一年 他给你免费送了。
那么M5 M7他的兜底的上限是300万 M9 还有一些直接的高端就是500万。
那么他是不包含城市NOA的 这里面注意啊 他是高速NOA 他跟比亚迪是不一样的。
因为你要如果用过这个华为的ADS支架 因为我一直在开嘛？
就是他在高速领航真的是非常好用 真的非常好用 我我不太敢讲 就是其实真的是。
你懂的 懂的都懂的啊 真的是就是你只要一上高速你开启之后。
你们那个词说出来就违规嘛 但是我其实经常在高速上就是让他开。
但是手要扶方向盘啊 眼睛要看正前方啊 但是真的非常好用。
但是因为他就对自己的技术自信嘛 他就说我兜底嘛 对吧 他就兜底嘛 所以他是高速兜底 但城区。
城市NOA不兜底 里培先走车主的车鞋 哎 这也是跟比亚迪不一样啊 他是里培先走车主的车鞋。
然后XR有厂家来补。
XR来补 他不是说我直接兜底 就不要走保险 两个概念。
那么小鹏的XNGP目前是什么呢 收钱。
239块钱一年 自费购买 那肯定有些时候买车他也会搞活动送啊 但是反正这个定价就是239。
这个叫安心行
那么全年的赔付上限100万啊 这个没有旁边的鸿蒙那么高 那因为他车的平均单价低嘛 他没有鸿蒙系的平均单价高嘛？
他这个100万他是包含高速和城区NOA这两个都保。
然后这个NGP退出的5秒之内出现 也是在保障范围之内的 这个很关键啊？
NGP退出5秒之内是人的一个反应的时间 如果出了事故他也是保的。
但是呢 这个是要收费啊 这个就跟那个比亚迪也不太一样。
然后理想和未来呢 目前还没有推出过一些什么厂家兜底的政策啊 你就正常走保险就可以了。
那么这些车企他为什么不去学比亚底呢 为什么不学呢 其实说白了 不是所有的车企都适合走品牌自赔这条路的。
品牌自赔 你必须要满足几个条件 首先你要有足够多的车辆数据啊？
你要有足够强的这个系统控制能力啊 然后你还要能承受赔付波动的现金流。
那么也许比方这个月就那么一两个人过来找你理赔。
结果到了下个月可能有一二十个 甚至一两百个 那你这个钱必须要到账的 你不到让你只要出问题的 会出舆论风险的。
对吧 你这个有先行流能支撑吗？
华为的质价强 确实是很强 但它不是整车的制造企业啊 特斯拉的体系成熟也没有错 但它的责任框架是全球化的。
它不能随便去承诺的 那么其他的一些新实力的技术上可能是有些亮点。
但是不管是从规模成本先行流 还有包括整个的这个社会网络。
它未必能支撑 它的这个无上线的兜底啊 上不封顶啊 你想跟比亚迪 你肯定是按照比亚迪的规则来。
比亚迪说我上不封顶 你是不是也能上不封顶啊 你如果一旦你也跟了 可是你的条件没有比亚迪那么好。
那么反而不是被别人说吗 对不对 你要么就别跟 你要跟 你要么就跟比亚迪一样 要么你政策就比比亚迪还要好。
这就叫竞争嘛 所以比亚迪的这个支架都底 相当于是把自己的规模啊？
供应链啊 售后啊 成本啊 支架体系就一起给它压上去了。
它是综合体系化竞争 就像我今年一开始开年的时候就在讲。
我说今年不是比谁家的技术更先进 而是比生态是比体系。
就是买的是体系买的是生态 根本就不是买的某一个功能了。
所以今年不要再跟我谈说 刀哥啊 我能不能买什么什么车型 一些冷门的车型 冷门车型不用看了。
至少在 就是我们讲新能源这个体系里面 冷门车不用看了。
因为冷门车最根本的问题点是在于。
它从软件层面上 它硬件可以去七平八糟的在市面上去采。
但是它的软件层面上 系统的整个体系化的层面上来讲。
它支撑不了多久的 真的是支撑不了多久的。
所以呢比亚迪他敢玩这个支架的都底 其实他核心的逻辑就三点。
首先一点就是比亚迪他是不是展示了一个。
叫做玄机A3自研车规辑什么四纳米芯片 对吧？
他为什么要掌握这个东西 其实说白了 不是说芯片的参数有多吓人。
当然了 车规辑的芯片的制造难度确实是比。
结果我们讲就是消费级的 就是手机上的这种芯片要难很多。
因为你手机说白了一两年就坏了嘛 用的多了三四年就坏了嘛？
但是车你想每个人开车一两年就换车不可能的吧？
你都肯定要开个五六年 七八年甚至十几年。
但他不管你开几年 厂家对于车上这些零部件的要求肯定是至少保证十年以上。
是不是 他能稳定能耐用 而且手机如果说芯片出了点问题。
那说白了 死机重启就行了 你车机出问题 你开玩笑 你开着高速上。
你开到城区人流密集的地方 你这能出问题吗 肯定是不能出问题的。
然后你到了一些什么墨盒 黑盒这种什么零下三四十度的地方。
你手机说没电就没电了 那这个不是芯片的问题。
但是你说在这个车上零下四十度大太阳。
不是零上四十度
就是大夏天零上四十度大太阳 你爆晒。
晒个一人天 那你电火就得走啊 不叫点火 就是你启动上了电你就得走。
是不是 你说不行 芯片它过热 散热不行 芯片出故障了。
你要再让它散火热 休息一会才能走 你等个两分钟行不行 你不要那么急嘛 你等个两分钟不行啊？
你开玩笑一个车子让你等两分钟 让芯片散热散完再能走 你说这个车你会买吗 那不可能的嘛？
所以这个车规级芯片的研发难度确实是比这个消费级的这种芯片要难很多。
而且上来就是干司纳米 其实比阿迪玩芯片很早很早 只不过他一直是埋着头在搞。
埋着头在搞 他现在要么就不出招 一出招就是大招 对吧？
那么同时他这个芯片现在掌握在自己手里面了。
就意味着就比阿迪是把芯片算法 整车控制 这些核心的环节。
都掌握在自己的体系里面 而且我记得比阿迪当时宣传说自己是有经营原厂 是吧？
就是他是可以自己去提炼那个。
沙子嘛 我们知道芯片是从沙子开始一点一点提炼出来的 非常牛掰啊？
那么很多的车企他其实打不到这一点 很多车企他其实是做支架。
就是芯片 算法 传感器 执行系统 他就是找各种不同的供应商 把它整合在一起嘛？
那么你想 整合确实很方便 对吧 你找到供应商就行了 但是一旦要出事呢？
一旦要是出事了 这个责任链条其实很容易就变成TP球了。
大家知道之前那个吉利不是和新旺达 就是因为那个电池的问题 两个人打官司嘛？
那不就最典型的嘛 就是你是我的供应商 现在 哎 电池出问题了 新旺达说对不起 这是你车的问题。
那吉利说对不起 这是你电池的问题 然后最后两个人写伤嘛 然后也有可能一部分是我的 有可能一部分是你的。
他就容易TP球了 但是你想想看 这比亚迪是什么概念。
比亚迪的芯片的工程师 可能跟底盘调校工程师 就在一栋楼里面上班。
他们中午可能就在一张桌子上吃饭 对吧 那出楼问题 公司内部开个柜就把事情给解决了嘛？
你就不会不会出现这种什么TP球的事情 里面你是一家车企嘛？
就是消费者出楼问题 第一反应是找CS店 说白了就是找品牌。
那你品牌你在网上找那是你的事 你跟我不相干。
所以你说是芯片问题 他说是算法问题 算法说成感器的问题 最后其实。
那谁的问题是车主的问题啊 那最后怎么办呢 那就解决提出问题的人嘛 对吧 谁提出问题就解决提出问题的人。
解决了之后不就没有问题了嘛 私下协商 车主山铁 这都是传统的剧本了 对不对。
大家经常在网上能看到 车主一开始特别的气愤 联罚几条 联罚两三天 突然之间那个账号就清空了 为什么呀？
谈妥了吗 对不对 解决提出问题的人 是吧 其实我跟你讲 这件事情我觉得就是说掌握芯片 掌握字眼这些东西 我打个不恰当的比喻啊？
其实全赞字眼和用供应商的技术就等同于用大佬去控制你的手脚和别人指挥你动手动脚。
就这么个区别 你说抬左手抬右手抬左脚抬右脚行不行 行 没有问题。
但是跟我脑海里面说抬左手抬右手抬左脚抬右脚抬右脚 这种反应速度。
就是抬也抬了嘛 这个速度可能就是差了没一点点 就差了没一点点。
他的整个的系统之间的壁垒他可以打破 第一点 第二点是什么呢 他是有足够多的真实的道路数据。
比亚迪你想想看他卖了多少辆车了 从宣布全民支架开始 车上都给你配支架 他为什么都配啊？
比亚迪那么扣成本的一个企业 他为什么要配啊 支架不是实验室里面闭门造车。
中国的城市道路是非常复杂的 东南西北中都是不一样的。
对吧 不是说大家都按照车道线去行驶 对不对。
在中国你按照车道线行驶 那效率是非常低的。
那么很多都不讲规则的车 不讲规则的人啊 什么鬼探头了啊 外卖小哥横冲直撞了 路边围停了。
对吧 还有临时施工啊 一大早高峰机动不动搞个洒水车什么的。
对吧 你也不知道为什么堵车 开到前面一看 说那边再给这个花花草草浇水。
哈哈哈 对吧 什么电动车突然变到闯红灯啊 这种常委的场景太多太多了。
那么这种支架 你需要怎么去训练。
那就是老司机吗 就把他当人一样去训吗 那老司机也得是长时间开车开出来的。
所以说比亚迪现在搭载天神之眼的车辆规模足够大 跑的地方足够多。
有足够多的案例 足够多的这个行驶里程 见过足够多的场景。
就是把这些复杂的数据复杂的东西全部处理完 数据多了 其实不一定代表最强更强。
也不代表说永远不出售 但是他至少给酸法提供了一个持续进化的土壤啊 对吧 每天向前一小步。
那么系统见得多 判断才会有机会更稳啊 施工力才有机会往下降啊 那么兜底的成本是不是才能可控啊？
所以这就是他其实在玩一个 怎么讲呢 就是规模效应。
以前我们讲车造的多 那么成本就低 现在其实就是你车卖的带质价的多 你将来其实兜底的成本就低。
那就是这么个逻辑 那么第三层是什么呢 就是比亚迪其实是把责任链和成本链 这两个链条算得很清楚。
就兜底他现在不是喊口号来 就是我要掏钱真的赔了。
那而且他说我是无上限赔付 对吧 他背后肯定是要找精算师去算。
就是这个出事故赔付的概率大概是多少 维修的成本大概是多少 社会的流程到底应该怎么跑。
对吧 那比亚迪现在的优势是什么呢 三电 整车制造 还有部分的一些核心的零部件。
社会维修这些环节 他掌握的都比较深 所以他垂直的整合能力比较强。
那么出了问题之后 他是比较容易去找这个问题的定位点 到点哪个地方出了问题。
那么他将来还可以去修复这些问题点 对不对 对他来讲也是个改进嘛？
因为这确定是个bug了 我就可以把它改掉嘛 那改掉之后下次我就不会再因为这个bug。
出现问题再赔付 是不是这样 所以他可能对自己的这方面的不管说是迭代。
速度也好 还是说这个bug的修复的能力也好 他是比较自信的。
他觉得我的质价不一定现在是最强的 但是我这么一说出去 你都过来找我赔付了。
你比较说你以前不找我赔付的时候 可能出了个bug 我也不知道。
但是现在 你但凡质价出了问题 你都来找我 那么所有的这些用比亚迪质价的人不就是他免费的测试员吗？
对不对 讲起来是我是找你赔付的 但是实际上比亚迪用你这个案例去看一看我的质价是不是有bug。
如果有了bug了 那相当于就是 我付个钱给你 我付钱给你 相当于就是你帮我去弥补了bug嘛？
哎 你按照这个逻辑来讲 什么赔付不赔付啊 相当于是我在帮你去修复bug呀 是不是。
所以他说什么无上信 就讲白了 让你就遇到事情就跟他讲 遇到事故就往上报就可以了。
对吧 你也别写麻烦 他都已经跟你讲兜底了 你怕什么麻烦。
但前提 我还是 我想宣传一下 你真的用了质价了 你在。
你不确定的情况下 你去报给比亚迪 你如果连质价你都没开启 你出了事故你就报 那你不是给他增添麻烦嘛？
对不对 所以这件事情其实听起来很猛 但是真正落地 我觉得比亚迪这边。
还是非常有压力的 我不知道是不是真的能百分之百执行的非常好 所以咱们拭目以待。
那么有人讲说 有没有真实的赔付案例呢 虽然说这个时间非常短啊 5月28号宣布的 今天才6月4号。
但是我想告诉你 已经有赔付案例了 而且就在5月29号的晚上。
有人撞了车 这是一辆藤氏Z9GT的车主 他还有小红书的账号 叫。
那尼可真心
尼娜那尼 就是女子旁的那女子旁的尼 那尼可真心。
不是可真心啊 心就是心心的心 你搜一下那尼可真心啊 最近还蛮火的啊？
按照他的说法啊 在5月29号晚上 也就是28号比亚迪宣布城市领航兜底政策的第二天。
他当时开车在一个路口 跟着一个特斯拉后面掉头。
那么掉头的过程当中 已经是两台车接近于并排了 然后特斯拉突然停下来了。
质价没有识别到 还在往前行驶 结果呢 跟特斯拉发生了刮草。
那么他的这台车呢 是今年3月份上市的藤氏Z9GT闪充版。
车主提车大概是在4月份啊 4月中那样子。
那么这台车子呢 他贴了一套黑武士的这个车衣。
那么事故发生前 就是5月28号。
就当时他就升级到了天生之眼B 5.0的版本 这个非常重要啊？
他是升级完了之后才发生了这个事故。
那么升级了这个版本 他也领取了CNOA城市领航辅助的叫那个兜底权益。
也就是说从前置条件上来讲 他已经是完全符合比亚迪的这个兜底政策了。
那么我在他的这个视频里面 我也看了一下。
他当时也发了一个叫做城市领航兜底的必要条件。
就是第一个就是天神之眼A 天神之眼B 你必须升级到5.0。
那么第二一个就是权益中心 你要领取CNOA城市领航兜底的权益。
第三一个就是事故发生前没有存在人机互搏的行为。
这是他当时展示的一个必要条件。
那么怎么去申请呢 要带什么材料呢？
那么首先就是行驶证 驾驶证 还有就是交警的事故责任认定书。
还有就是事故时的行车记录仪的原始视频。
然后就是天神之眼的版本界面截图 就像我刚刚讲的。
就一定要升级到5.0。
还有就是权益中心CNOA城市领航兜底权益的截图。
那么这个当事人就是Z9GT的车主陈屿是。
他接下来就是把车辆开回到了CS店。
然后提交了相关的材料 就刚刚上面说的这些材料。
那么比亚迪就开始在后台去调取相关数据。
那么最后呢 比亚迪是在5月30号的下午完成了技术勘查。
确认这些事故是符合城市领航兜底的权益范围。
那么就开始启动兜底的赔付。
也就是说车主发生事故5月29号的晚上。
然后比亚迪确认赔付5月30号的下午。
一天都不到啊？
一天的时间就完成了赔付。
所以这个事情肯定也是比亚迪拿来做宣传的嘛？
对吧 那如果以后真的比亚迪的赔付效率那么高。
认定责任的效率那么高。
那我相信很多人是愿意首选的 对不对。
那你想想看 我买这个车也是买 买那个车也是买。
但是我想了想那比亚迪的质价我是真的用啊 我真敢用啊？
因为用完之后你想想这个陈小姐 对吧？
那她撞了她就是赔了。
那有的人真的会这么想真的会这么想。
那赔什么呢？
因为我们前面讲了嘛？
就一定要是你有责她才赔。
那车辆的维修费用比亚迪承担。
车医的损失贴了个黑武士也是比亚迪承担。
前车的损失那个特斯拉的损失还是比亚迪承担。
所以这个案例的意义是什么？
就是至少说明比亚迪他不是说就嘴上说说就算了。
他现在真的是在跑这个流程。
这个流程真的是跑起来了。
但这个流程现在有人讲了。
他这个是小金额的佩服啊？
你跑起来是快啊？
对吧 他毕竟是没有人伤事故啊？
责任的这个边界判定的也是比较的容易的。
那么今后如果遇到更复杂的多车追尾。
对吧 然后这个人伤事故。
多人的人伤事故
驾驶员的这个接管边界如果不是很清晰。
系统的提示跟人工的操作是交织在一起。
那你还能不能这么快速的去认定呢？
你处理起来还能不能那么的透明呢？
还能不能让消费者幸福呢？
这都不好说
所以只能讲是拭目以待。
那至少现在有个车企他敢这么玩。
那咱们就先看着呗。
对不对 先看着呗。
所以呢 质价兜底这件事情呢？
你把它当成是一个营销的手段也是ok的。
但是他确确实实也是真金白银拿出来赔偿的一个承诺。
那我以前一直觉得就是质价兜底这种事情。
质价 质价本身就因人而异啊？
就像这个郭山车有人敢做有人不敢做。
那那郭山车的管理员肯定讲这是安全的嘛？
那全世界那么多的郭山车。
那出事故的概率是极低的。
但是他多多少少还是有那么一点概率。
对不对
那有人愿意去尝试。
有人愿意去尝试
那肯定也有不愿意的。
有那些保守的用户啊？
那我就老老实实开车。
我就是守护方盘脚踩油门上车。
对吧 你再怎么兜底我不用啊？
但是现在兜底之后他用了还是不用呢？
一开始我觉得兜不兜底该用还是用。
该不用还是不用
但是我看到比亚迪的发布会上有个PBT。
有一页是这么写的。
说智能驳车自从比亚迪宣布驳车兜底的承诺之后。
使用率翻了4倍
这个是我没想到的。
翻了4倍多
他也没说具体一开始的使用率有多少。
我觉得这个原始的使用率应该就不低了。
如果是10%翻4倍也50%了。
如果是20%再翻4倍就接近100%了。
他说翻了4倍
所以我不知道什么概率。
反正很多人他不是不知道这个功能好。
而是他其实心里面害怕。
他就是怕万一要出了事情。
这个锅要自己背
又不是自己开的还要自己背。
是不是
那么如果厂家兜底。
那我是不是就可以用了。
那一旦要出了问题对不起你说兜底的。
那么这个成本是由你来制服。
所以就这么一个承诺。
能让他的智能驾驶辅助系统能翻4倍。
其实从某种意义上讲。
你想一想
对厂家其实也是有利的。
因为所谓的跑数据。
他不是说车上有这个功能。
这个数据就能跑起来。
而是有这个功能之后。
你得要用
他这个数据才能跑起来。
算法才能继续去进化。
所以这个质价不是停留在什么配置单上面的。
你说
1000万的人买了你们家的车。
都是有质价的
但是里面有800万没用。
就那么200万的车。
他在跑才得用
但是如果做一旦兜底的话。
你卖出去1000万辆。
那就是1000万辆车。
它真的是每天都在用。
那个数据的
这种规模量
那简直你要翻4倍。
我估计那整个的数据量。
都翻得不止4倍
你只有用户真的去打开它。
用它
它才会真正将来持续迭代。
形成它的一个产品精神力。
所以这个比较低的。
滴滴兜兜
滴兜兜就是这个质价兜底。
就说白了
它是整个字眼能力。
车辆的规模
销售的数据
真实的数据
成本的控制
售后的体系
现金流的成压
它是一环都不能少。
少一项都兜不了
少一项这就是从战略变成赌博了。
就是从营销变成赌博了。
所以你看比亚迪这一次。
他说我把责任我放在桌面上。
我给你说了
我兜底
而且不是上线
虽然网上还有一些正义。
但是我觉得整个行业。
其实都是在盯着
可能有些人还是比较难受的。
但是也是在盯着
所以我就讲了
大家现在还没跟进。
但是很多品牌
它肯定也要想起到的办法。
就是我跟还是不跟。
我怎么跟
现在肯定是连夜在开会。
因为离5月28号。
也就才一个星期左右。
因为这里面会出现个很现实的问题。
就是以后不管任何品牌说。
我的质价怎么怎么强。
我比有商怎么怎么强。
那可能消费者到4S店。
就是会问这么一句。
强 我承认
但是万一出的事
你赔还是不赔
好的
以上就是本期节目的主要内容。
咱们也不管其他的车脊赔不赔。
反正京东的大墙子的红包。
肯定是会免费送的。
这个弯拐的有点大。
京东跟我们摆设悬说。
联合定制的京东红包。
就在我们的评论区。
置顶的链接
大家点击就可以领取了。
红包是可以跟折扣卷。
叠加使用的
每天最多领三次
先领红包
再下单
记得一定要看清楚有效期。
那么小宇之后跟喜马拉雅。
听到最后的听音有如果没有订阅的。
可以动动发台的小手指订阅一下。
那么喜马拉雅播放的页面。
下方有免费的月票。
如果方便可以给我投一投。
增加我的排名往前靠一靠。
那么我们每期节目的评论区。
会抽三位
赠送由人言计提供的苹果翠两代。
那么下面是关于上期节目的留言互动。
上期节目咱们聊了尊介即刻。
未来理想仰望谁才是底盘的天花板。
我看了一下
不管是音频还是图文。
流量还可以
大家都比较地感兴趣。
但是也有一些人觉得。
这样的内容比较地枯燥。
其实说句实在话
我现在已经不管说你觉得枯燥还是不枯燥了。
我觉得这件事情是对的。
我就坚持做
你说无聊
你说节目做得不好。
你说不爱听
那就你先告辞
没关系
就这一期你先不听。
以后我知道你想听什么？
落家常聊故事
会有
一定会有的
慢慢来
来日方长
一年一百多期节目呢？
对不对
你让我讲几期干的吧？
你再不讲几期干的。
别人又说三刀没什么真凭食料。
当然了有人讲说
你就算有这些什么相关的数据。
你也是往上查的
这年头你这我又不是百科全书。
我是百舍全书
对吧？
那你现在有AI接住AI。
去搜集相关的数据。
我再去多方的论证。
然后把我知道的一些内容分享给大家。
这不挺好的吗？
你也省了时间
我也长了知识
大家一起学习
对不对
上期节目呢？
有一个可恶的地方。
说这个理想L9 Lewis。
800福德主动全挂。
这个一万扭是蹲击。
我当时说成了一千扭蹲击。
很多人就在评论区给我纠正一下。
说一千扭倒不了蹲击。
是一万一万
不是一千
这里面给大家稍微看个物。
那么上期节目有位听友叫做许愿Eason。
Eason
他说听完这期节目我就感觉。
以后新能源车的后期维修成本。
那可是非常非常的高啊？
的确是这样的
你别说主动全挂了。
你就是空气全挂
现在很多人都很担心。
所以现在不就买颜宝吗？
很多的新车
现在新能源交付当天。
销售是不是就跟你讲了。
说我们这个车子哪些部件是终生的。
哪些部件是三年的。
你要不要再附加一个整车的终生的颜宝。
就让你去买了
一万多块钱吗？
或者是八九千块钱吗？
那么你现在如果不买的话。
等到你快过宝的时候。
你再去买这个延长质宝。
那对不起
价格就不是现在了。
这样了
就是你现在八千的那个时候。
可能就卖一万二
那么有人讲说要不要买值不值得买。
其实说实话
主要还是看第一个你开的时长。
三年五年还是八年十年。
第二个是看你开的这个路况。
如果就是非常好的城市的铺装道路。
每天两点一线
偶尔周末自驾跑的也是高速公路。
那我觉得正常开也没啥问题。
对不对
那你实在是担心了吗？
那就你先开着呗
两三年之后你到时候再买嘛？
那么买的话你一定要看清楚。
是厂家的这个延长质宝侦测。
全国联保的
还是经销商4S店给你提供的。
那么一般后者会相对便宜一点。
但是后者的这种延长质宝的话。
他的质宝期限不是合同上的期限。
是这家经销商能活多久的期限。
因为现在很多经销商。
开着开着就不开了嘛？
就老板跑路了嘛？
有的经销商开着开着。
可能今天代理这个品牌。
明天就不代理了
你让他还怎么给你质宝呢？
他都没有收获了
他怎么质宝呢？
对不对
那有良心的嘛？
可能获得一些大的经销商集团。
还能帮你转到别的店。
那没有良心的就不管了嘛？
所以最好的是买厂家的。
那稍微贵一点就稍微贵一点吧？
对吧？
确确实实这些
很有可能后期成本会高一些。
那么下面一位听友叫做QC不是魁北克。
他说三刀我不懂就问有。
就以前我开大型的SUV转弯的过程中。
包括高速编导的过程中。
会有明显的侧倾的感觉。
那么这个一定程度上会让我降低车速。
但如果说有了主动全价。
我没有了侧倾感
那我就不会去控制车速了。
那会不会更危险呢？
主动全价能够提升SUV的迷路测试成绩吗？
其实问这个问题的不是这一位听友。
我看到评论区包括知识星球上。
也有人在提这个问题。
那我想讲就是有
确确实实会有这种风险。
就是你对速度的感知。
可能会变得稍微弱一点。
因为主动全价它能压得住侧倾吗？
就车子不会明显
就是压着低面再开侧倾再开。
它让车身姿态会更加的稳。
那么迷路的成绩肯定也是会提升的。
但是它改变不了车重。
改变不了重心
改变不了轮胎的抓地极限。
那么问题就是
人如果没有侧倾感。
很容易去误判它的操作极限。
那么你以为你还能更快。
但是实际上车已经不能更快了嘛？
那么真正安全的逻辑就是。
首先你要控制在安全的车速范围内。
那我相信你不可能。
八九十公里每小时去过弯的。
你降到个四十公里每小时。
那是不是主动全价其实也不重要了。
你包括你开到一些。
这种飞铺装路面
碎石路面
还有一些烂路上
你不可能看到个坑踩着油门就往上冲。
对不对
主动全价是提高了容错。
但不是鼓励你开的更快。
这毕竟是大型的SUV。
中大型SUV
它不是当赛车开的。
对吧？
那么第三位听友呢？
叫ROGICS Logix。
他说
他其实也没说傻了。
他就是每一天
都在咱们的知识性求上。
去分享他新疆阿拉带的自驾游。
我非常欢迎大家去分享。
这些自驾游的攻略。
那么之前我们有期节目也是说了。
哇
就一年分享了十几天。
从南京一路自驾过去的。
那么我们也是给点鼓励。
我觉得不过分
那么ROGICS他也是。
从现在开始是第三天。
第二天他生了个病。
第二天没自驾
带着他媳妇去医院了。
去阿拉带的医院
我说你去医院也能分享一下。
就是阿拉带看病指南嘛？
对吧？
当然了
我祝他早日康复
但是因为都很熟悉的。
所以我说
那你其实也可以分享一下。
就万一要是自驾过程中出现了。
这个感冒发烧什么的。
多多少少能给我们一些。
看病的一些这种
有个指南肯定好嘛？
像这种攻略我觉得非常有意思。
大家如果想看也可以上我的知识星球。
联系盾牌46415254。
就可以看他现在还在持续更新。
今天已经是更新到第三篇了。
非常不错
所以我觉得应该送点小离品鼓励一下。
那么我最近也在想。
知识星球我还是要抽奖。
除了这些奖以外
我还要再抽其他的奖。
就是鼓励大家来到我们星球里面。
你感受一下
就是你平时有一些。
朋友圈不太好说的话。
然后微博像这种社交媒体上就更不能说了。
你在知识星球这种付费的私余社群里面。
有那么两三千人
三四千人
我具体多少我现在也没看了。
就是有这么多人在一起。
大家你不认识我我不认识你。
但是因为我三刀俱到一起。
而且都是付费进来的。
这个圈子非常的干净。
而且大家非常的和谐。
没有那些乌七八糟的事情。
每一天大家分享生活。
大家会去分享一些自己的。
比方说这个疑惑
像我们的球友去提问。
或者是像我三刀
每个月都可以找我去提问。
你其实发帖一般我也会回复的。
那么这样一来的话就感觉非常的好。
反正我每天我都会花很多时间。
去刷我的这个知识星球。
感兴趣的话可以加入。
就是添加微信46415254就可以了。
然后有一件事情
其实五月底就应该宣布了。
这事情给我搞忘了。
最近比较忙
就是我马上要出书了。
但是这个马上可能还是比较久。
因为跟出版社签的是。
大概在明年8月份最迟。
那么目前按照时间进度规划的话。
因为我前沿已经写完了。
第一章的五个节
五小节已经写完了。
那总个规划大概十一章到十二章的样子。
这个书的名字叫波克变现。
因为我看到很多的一些听诱。
其实还是想做内容的。
然后波克又是属于。
相对来讲成本比较低。
门槛也是就入门的门槛比较低的。
有个麦克风就能录了嘛？
但是具体说什么？
怎么做 怎么选题。
波克到底怎么变现。
其实波克是非常适合兼职当一个。
副业来做的这么一件事。
但是它到底有多少的上限。
就这个体系
你的自媒体的我们讲叫举证。
自媒体账号 个人IP。
到底应该怎么做
那么这本书我规划了一下。
目录有机会我可以发在我们的群里面。
如果大家感兴趣回头。
我也可以拉一个群。
就是三刀的这本书叫波克变现。
我拉一个波克变现这本书的这个群。
因为现在已经是正式跟。
中国人民邮店出版社签合同了。
其实上个月的月底就签了。
人邮跟人邮签的
也是非常感谢我们的一位听友。
叫专三签
就之前在寒寒的工作室工作。
然后后来自己独立出来自己做。
做付费阅读
他非常厉害
他相当于是我这边跟出版社。
沟通的全全的代理。
那么我跟他签合同。
他跟人民邮店出版社签合同。
那么很快就把这个事情给搞定了。
那么因此我大概最快就是。
明年过年前后这本书能出来。
最慢的话大概在8月前后。
那么这本书一方面是相当于。
我这么多年工作的一个总结。
做自媒体的一个经验的总结。
那么也有很多我的一些故事。
就是创业的故事
个人的一些故事在这里面。
那么更多的还是让它。
偏向于工具化一些。
就是你拿到手就能用。
看完之后你就明白了。
原来音频波克是这么回事。
是这么做的
因为这么选题
这么录这么捡
设备是这么买
他的商业的上线在哪。
他的对于你个人IP的一个拓展。
到底是有哪些好的跟不好的。
我还会写很多我的失败的案例。
你光写成功的没什么意思了。
这不是个人自传
这是一个我把它定位是更偏向于。
这么多年经验的总决。
偏向于工具的一本书。
因为人有也是偏向于。
更适合出工具类的书籍的。
这样的一个出版社。
中国人民邮店出版社。
所以他们也给了我。
很多的一些建议
就是说你刚开始
先把自己的身份交在清楚之后。
很快你要切入到主题。
就是一定要去讲很干货的东西。
因为现在这个年代。
大家都是希望能有一份。
怎么讲呢？
就是入门比较轻松。
然后能够让自己不管是得利。
或者是得名
这么一份兼职
对吧？
我用我的业余时间。
我能不能让我的行业知名度更高。
那有名就有利
或者说我直接让他去变现。
所以这本书的名字就叫波克变现。
今天算是我第一次在我的节目里面。
就正式去讲这个事。
那以后有机会的话。
跟大家再去同步一下。
我的出书的进度吧？
说句实在话
我真的有点不好意思。
像我这么一个
又没有什么很高的学历。
然后说句实在话
我写东西也没什么文采。
就是写
确实我说句良心话。
我这么多年我写了不少字。
因为我写音频稿
写视频稿
那每天都是在跟文字打大交道。
我从来没想过
我三刀金
今后能成为一个马字的。
以文字为生的这么一个人。
我从来没想过
因为我以前语文也不是特别好。
而且我写字也比较丑。
语文老师也特别不喜欢我。
我也不喜欢语文老师。
但是这张嘴确实还是挺能讲的。
但是嘴能讲和你手能写。
这是两回事
所以写书这件事情。
我心里面一直没有底。
也是感谢专三千一直在鼓励我。
说三刀你可以写
真的可以写
他说你哪怕你就是不想写。
你说你把它录下来。
我给你写
你想他都已经把话说到这个分上了。
你说我写还是不写。
所以就这么阴差阳错的。
就把这个事情给促成了。
所以希望大家
就是今后能不能支持支持。
就这个书铁定是要出了。
那么要不出我就违约了。
合同都已经签好了。
那出了以后
兄弟们评证区能不能告诉我。
你准备买几本
亲门好友都送一送是吧？
因为我们一开始签合同很有意思。
我第一次参与了完整的出出的邮程。
它是也有出版的要求。
就是它比方讲第一批印刷。
首印是多少本
具体首印是多少本。
我还真没看
三千还是一千两千。
然后他们也跟我讲说。
目前市面上关于播客的书籍。
卖的最好的是一个严终花续。
还是谁
他们出了一本书
说也就一共卖了不到两千本。
我在想说
他都不到两千本
那你就不能给我要求太高了。
所以我在想
但他们会说
那你粉丝那么多
你粉丝那么多
你卖个两三千应该问题不大。
我说这个不一样
我说听节目的粉丝和买书的人。
他可能不是一类人群。
而且本身就是个播客变现。
第一个你要这个人。
他对播客感兴趣
我全网的粉丝量还可以。
但是播客的粉丝量就摆在这。
虽然也不少
但是现在能持续还在听的。
有多少
这个还真不太清楚。
那么第二一个就是。
这里面有多少人
真的能愿意捧着一本书去看的。
有的人说
那我不看
我买回来
我支持一下三导你。
可不可以
当然可以了
那我也很感谢你
所以这个我觉得是为了名誉而战。
而不是这本书真的你买得多。
我能挣多少钱
版税其实没多少
我看了一下版税真的。
跟自媒体就完全不能比。
但这件事情我觉得真的对于我来讲很有意义。
那么对于大家来讲。
是不是对三导这本书要支持和鼓励一下。
到时候就看真实的销量数据吧？
好那么以上就是本期节目所有的内容。
感谢大家收看
如果说想要关注我更多的内容。
可以去在Bilibili搜索我的长视频的频道。
摆车全说账号
还有就是短视频
在小红书抖音视频号快手搜索三刀砍车。
砍大山的砍
那么另外我的微博叫摆车全说三刀。
每天都有更新
还有我们的公众号摆车全说。
也是每天都有更新。
想要连续我们
想要加入我们的社群。
想要跟我单独交流的话。
都可以添加微信46415254。
今天这期节目就到这里。
我们下期节儿聊
拜拜